and then behind those two things behind
the shadow and the anima and the animus
there's a final archetype which is the
archetype of the self and that's Jung
believed that the self was what you were
as a totality and that's a hard thing to
understand but but you could think about
it this way you could think about the
self as the as the total of what you are
now plus the total of all those things
that you could still be so it would be
you as a reality plus you as potential
and that's a strange idea right because
we don't really know how to understand
the idea of potential as modern
empirical people because potential
virtually by definition is not yet
manifest and also not a straightforward
thing to either measure or conceptualize
by the same token everybody acts as if
they're they have potential unrealized
potential
and so you generated up a category to
account for that which he felt was
expressed in all sorts of symbolic way
so for example the wise old man like
like the Wizards in in the movies that
all of you have seen in the last five
years it's always the same Wizard
sometimes it's even the same actor it's
like that's an archetype of the wise old
man and for young Christ was an
archetype of the self as well and I told
you why that was to some degree and it's
partly because the Phoenix is also an
archetype of the self because the
Phoenix is something that can die and be
reborn and so the Phoenix stands for the
part of your personality that can let
one thing go one part of you which is in
the live part can let that go and burn
up so to speak so that something new can
be born because you very seldom gain
something before you let something else
go because that's partly because what
you already assume can be the worst
impediment that you have to work to
learning something new and it's
complicated because sometimes what you
know worked in the past you know so you
can think about that maybe you're a
perfectly well adapted 11 you
and you're still acting that way when
you're 15 it's like well it's hard to
let that go because it worked and you
put a lot of effort into it but unless
you let it go the new personality isn't
going to be able to manifest itself so
you have to stop being a child before
you can be an adult and there's a
sacrifice that goes along with that it's
also a sacrifice that parents have to
make right because in order for a parent
to encourage you to adopt the
responsibilities of an individual they
have to allow you as a child to die and
Freud's observation on that phenomena
was that many parents and he believed
this was particularly characteristic of
mothers because of their tight bond with
their children and the dependency that
that implies that it was particularly
difficult for a mother to let her child
die so that an adult could manifest
itself in that child's place and that's
fundamentally in many ways the oedipal
complex okay so now I'm gonna show you
some of these things again because the
thing about young is that it's not easy
to understand what he has to say and
it's not a simple thing to explain it
and his books are complicated although I
don't think they're any more complicated
than they have to be like I don't think
young is obscure I think he's just
difficult and then beyond difficult he's
actually frightening so there's lots of
reasons that people don't like you